bitcoin coming back with a vengeance
after it dropped significantly over the
weekend now we've got a whole bunch of
stuff that is suggesting that there is
continued interest and demand in bitcoin
why is that important why is it
important to understand the demand
because it is a fixed supply asset
there's a fixed supply asset demand
increases the us dollar price has to
appreciate i don't care about short term
but i do care over a long period of time
so the first thing is that 55 of bitcoin
investors started in 2021 this is coming
from the grayscale bitcoin investor
study on top of that we have willy woo
explaining user base doubles every year
on average for the last decade absolute
explosive growth grayscale which is one
of the largest asset managers if not the
largest crypto native asset manager in
the world they have come out and they
have conducted the third annual bitcoin
investor study they've gone and here's
the methodology they have surveyed a
thousand people the response between the
ages of 25 and 64. those respondents are
the primary or shared responsibility for
making household financial decisions so
they have the decision-making power on
top of that they have at least ten
thousand dollars in household investable
assets and at least fifty thousand
dollars in invest in household income so
these people have some level of money
they have some level of income they make
decisions between the ages of 25 and 64.
and they got asked all these questions
about bitcoin now here are the key
takeaways from this grayscale bitcoin
investor study one
more than a quarter more than 26 percent
of investors already own bitcoin these
are united states people between the age
of 25 and 64. 26 already owned bitcoin
more than half 59 surveyed investors are
interested in bitcoin investments that
is a notable increase from 36 in 2019 55
in 2020. more than half also currently
owned bitcoin began investing in the
last 12 months they're new to the game
interest in bitcoin investment products
rose significantly among older people
over the last year 30 in 2020 over the
age of 55 now 46 about 50 growth in the
older cohorts female investors going
from 47 to 53 last year to this year and
then lastly most bitcoin owners 87 own
one or more other digital currencies now
here are my main takeaways from this one
26 i don't believe that number right i
do believe that there's been a
significant increase over time i do not
believe one in four americans own
bitcoin what my guess is is that there
is some bias in this data one it's
between the ages of 25 and 64 and it's
people that are already on the internet
so nationally you're going to get some
self uh selection into it i do believe
that it's a material percent it's a
double digit percent 26 percent i have a
hard time believing i hope i'm wrong but
that's my personal opinion the second
thing is that the older generation more
of the older people who start to
actually invest in this asset they have
the largest personal uh portfolios in
the legacy market two they're most
likely to hold gold which we know is
being demonetized based on the return
profile so they're more likely to drop
gold and buy bitcoin and then the third
thing is these are the people who
control corporations they control large
asset management firms they control
portfolios uh and also they work at the
accounting departments of large
companies as well and so once they start
to personally invest in these assets
then it becomes much more likely that
their companies their asset management
firms et cetera also start to invest in
these assets as well so it's very
important and then the last thing is
that bitcoin maximalism is the loud
minority 87 percent of people who own
bitcoin also own other digital
currencies you can read into that what
you want whether that's good or bad but
very very interesting to go ahead and
see that again the data you can argue
all day long is it actually a certain
percentage or is it not what is more
important to me is not so much the exact
numbers as much as the direction at
which we are seeing this more and more
people are interested more and more
people own it and more and more people
are continuing to allocate larger and
larger percentages of their portfolio to
these assets are we surprised by any of
the data that came out of this grayscale
bitcoin investor study no not
necessarily but i think it's for the
reasons you just said like everything
points directionally towards more people
acquiring bitcoin uh more people being
interested in the asset more people
allocating a larger portion of their
portfolio towards the asset and so on
but a thousand people is probably not
enough to uh to tell you direction one
way or the other whether something's
accurate obviously the people that
they're interviewing have some interest
in bitcoin and other cryptos but i think
when you look at it compared to other
studies we've done right even if you
just look at bitcoin's adoption rate
relative to the internet that's one of
the things that people love to compare
we're in the early early early innings
right not only that but internet i
believe was growing rebel paul came on
the show one time and said uh internet
at this point in its life cycle was
growing at like 65 percent per ov year
over year and bitcoin's growing over 100
year-over-year from an adoption
standpoint so i think we're still in the
early innings when it comes to how big
this can actually be we'll see what
happens over the next like five to ten
years probably it's going to take to
really play out but these studies are
great from a kind of shifting the
narrative perspective of telling us kind
of what's going on with individuals but
a thousand people is not nearly enough
to really grasp and be able to say hey
this is for sure what's happening with
the larger amount of population right
like 20 we know one in four people do
not own bitcoin i think anyone who says
that would be like no right and there's
studies that say anywhere from five
percent 10 25 and even 50
they've said uh people in america own
bitcoin so they're all over the place
and it really just depends on the size
the scale of the study and who they're
actually interviewing but i think
directionally yeah this is all pushing
in the right way john what do you think
directional yes it is pushing the right
way i actually am kind of i don't like
studies like this for the one reason of
it's a thousand people so you can kind
of manipulate the data however you want
as long as you target the right people
to answer the study and the answer kind
of however you want to spin your own
narrative i do think that directionally
a lot more people own bitcoin this year
than last year i do like the fact that
it has doubled its audience every single
year for the last decade or so so that's
really good bitcoin is the blue chip
stock right if you're into
cryptocurrency you're most likely into
bitcoin as well as if you're into other
cryptos so you kind of start with
bitcoin and then you kind of weed out
through all the other all coins and
everything so it's not surprising that
most people own bitcoin and then it's
also not surprising that if you own
bitcoin you are likely to own other
crypto assets yeah i i think that my uh
other big takeaway from this is that
grayscale which is a very very large
asset management firm uh they're using
this data to understand what they should
actually do from their products
understanding the sentiment and again it
goes back to uh every asset this is true
uh it's a supply and demand game if you
are looking at this from a pure
understanding of what is the supply what
is the demand but in this specific case
because it's a finite asset because we
understand there will never be more of
it then of course the demand becomes
even more important and what we are
watching is an entire generation across
demographics of uh people in terms of
internet times a lot of people think of
generations of like age i think of it as
people on the internet all at one time
right is there's an internet generation
all of these people they are all saying
there's undisciplined monetary and
fiscal policy in this country uh in the
united states and elsewhere in other
countries and now i need something that
no one can control no one can create
more of no one can debase no one can
manipulate in any way that affects my
purchasing power and that's why bitcoin
becomes so uh important yeah saying 26
of americans own bitcoin is like wild
that's a tough look
that's a tough look that's a tough one
the thing that frustrates me though
about some of this stuff is too like a
lot of people are getting their first
exposure to crypto and i say crypto
because that means everything right
through some of these [ __ ] coins or
coins that are not really going to be
anything right like if you look at the
total market today there's really only
one in my opinion maybe you could make
an argument for a few others that'll be
here guaranteed in the next five 10 15
years right and i it's frustrating to
see a bunch of people coming to the
asset class promised all these big
returns by people and look at it and say
hey these are coins that are going to
give you 2x 10x 15x20x when in reality
bitcoin is the most dominant you know
crypto in the market and that's the
safest bet relative to the risk reward
that you're gonna see yeah well i think
that there's uh people are optimizing
for different things so you were
optimizing for the greatest financial
return some people are optimizing for
durability right and if you're
optimizing for durability you go uh to
the most conservative end of the
spectrum right if you're optimizing for
the biggest returns then you end up
going to the other inspection the
problem is that you get paid a return
based on the risk you take and so if
you're looking for you know 20 000 extra
returns
you literally have a 0.001 chance of
success right it's why you take immense
risk for immense return but ultimately
what happens and you know from my
perspective i think from your
perspective is you actually want to kind
of sit in the middle i think a lot about
the majority of your portfolio even if
you want to like go be entertained right
if you want to go play a casino game
whatever like knock yourself out but for
the majority of your portfolio the way
that i look at mine is i want something
that is going to be conservative uh
relatively risk mitigated durable around
for a long time and also provides a good
enough return i don't need the best
return but i need a good enough return
so something like bitcoin which
historically has returned about 170
compound annual growth for the last
decade that seems to fit the bill
because it sits right at the
intersection now history doesn't
necessarily mean it's going to happen in
the future but again if we continue to
look at all the data and look at the
increase in demand seems pretty